ich habe einfach meine ganzen sachen
wieder gefunden die wir euch liebe dich
der fast nichts mitgenommen oder nur das
wichtigste halt ich habe ja auch nichts
gutes
danke hey leute und herzlich willkommen
zu einer weiteren folge minecraft hero
nachher zweitägiger pause war ich am
live stream zweimal gestorben bin ich
habe gesagt diese folgen die nächsten
folgen werden so produktiv wie sonst war
sein ich bin einfach nur daran zu
versuchen irgendwie zurück meine sachen
zu bekommen
deswegen ich habe meine sachen et cetera
pp ich muss jetzt irgendwie da hinten
hinkommen ich nehme jetzt noch ein
bisschen was zu essen mit also ich will
jetzt echt wirklich hab jetzt mir echt
vorhin war ein paar leute auf dem messer
war drauf das war nicht so geil
deswegen ich möchte einfach wirklich
meine ruhe haben bevor mich wirklich
irgend jemand dazwischen pushen kann
weil ich nach der aktion mit debitor ein
bisschen dessen rotes nach der aktion
mit debitor nach deckt somit debitoren
ein bisschen angst hat bieten seminare
werden dass ein fachseminar alter wie
geil ich habe dann einfach
wahrscheinlich ein schwarzes jackett
schwarzen weise sind die gleichen wenn
nicht bericht ich mich in den
kommentaren
ich brauche jetzt zu viele kommentare
wie es nur irgendwie geht die ihr mir
geben könnt was mal die koordinaten die
koordinatorin
dort waren die denn noch mal aber ich
glaube ich war da vorne ist haben oder
das nicht irgendwo dahinten
die waren aber die koordinaten auf jeden
fall war dieser zahl ganz hinten war auf
jeden fall irgendwie 800 glaube ich ich
hoffe mal dass es die koordinaten wann
ich jetzt richtig dahin laufe weil sonst
wer ein bisschen doof aber dass auf
jeden fall dieses komische häuslichen
dingsbums ich darf mir den job
übernehmen wir haben ja genug da hinten
das ist auf jeden fall nichts erlaubt
mir ist es auch erlaubt in andere städte
zu gehen weil bombay hat mir auch
erlaubt in andere städte gehen zu dürfen
der ist gerichtet mir genähten mexikaner
sind wir brauchen zu viele existenzen
wie es geht
also ich brauche diese ist das weg 82
guck mal hätte ich im blog jetzt
darunter nicht abgebaut hätten wir die
axiale zusätzlich wir kommen nicht mehr
weiter gelaufen aber ich werde da oben
noch eine was habe ich denn bitte für
morgen nicht jeder oben hexie kahle
sense worte vielleicht seht ihr gleich
auch wenn er wirklich eine ist dann habe
ich aber ich habe gute augen das hat
noch mein arzt mal gefragt aber ich
möchte irgendwie folge eine brille
ich habe ja bei instagram instagram dort
kommt der laser lokale werbung
ihr könnt ihr mir folgen wenn ihr wollt
wir nicht anders das kommando habe ich
gesehen aus dem augenwinkel ist das
krass ist der typ ein tier oder in tier
da habe ich ein bild gepostet wurden im
verlauf hatte dann alle hilfe aus wie
yoko völlig einfach nur eine brille
aber ich hätte echt richtig gerne brille
weil ich mag brillen und es gibt auch
richtig coole brillen und wenn eine
brille habt dann der sehschwäche dann
ich weiß nicht ich werde jetzt nicht so
traurig drüber weil man hat und man hat
dann natürlich natürlich auch vorteile
man kann sich nämlich auf die wirklich
wichtigen dinge im leben eine
fokussieren habe ich finde scheiß so gut
ich muss jedenfalls wieder zudem habe
ich die mexikaner sind gekommen ich hab
hier bekommt man das mal hier rein
bekommen welche mmogs mit schneebällen
du blödmann
wer kein leben verloren jetzt auch nur
ein schneeball ein schneemann erst gar
nicht ob ihr nie irgendjemand unterwegs
war mit mexikanischen zu suchen weil ich
habe jetzt schon wieder zwei gefunden
darum ist glaube ich keine ein bisschen
oder schon blutet bestimmt aber die
pfeile pfeilen im team wie nie an damit
ich weiß nicht warum die tat sich
jedenfalls alle meine sachen gekrallt
naja also man muss den tod eigentlich
meint eigentlich ganz gut sehen weil
durch den tod ist jetzt so eine art
kriegszustand mehr oder weniger sondern
so eine pre kriegszustand pre krieg gibt
es wurde weiß ich nicht er sondern vor
kriegszustand entstanden was auf jeden
fall richtig
irgendwie ist das cool finde ich das ist
jetzt ein bisschen anspannung in mir
diese mammut riesig die noch so heftige
sounds ich müsste eigentlich gleich da
sein ich weiß nicht ich will dich war
auf jeden fall hinter dem berg in der
ich müsste ich eigentlich irgendjemand
irgendwo hier ankommen diamanten brauche
ich auch eine menge war ich möchte mal
wieder muss ja wir wieder die trivial
rüstung möchte ich mir machen
die hatte ich übrigens nicht fertig hat
mir das mal im singleplayer noch mal
angeschaut mit der triba rüstung die ist
nur komplett richtig wenn man wirklich
nur teile von der triba richtung hat
also wenn ich da irgendwie ich hatte
davon ja nur ein teil und dachte dass
ich so ein bisschen die wirkung
mitnehmen könnte denkste war nämlich
nicht so dass jetzt
es wird nacht es wird einfach nachts ist
ärgerlich ich hoffe ein bisschen dahin
weil ich glaube dass wir da irgendwo ich
glaube ich kann mich daran erinnern dass
das hier war ich halte ja auch mal so
ein bisschen ausschau nach ich schon
wieder vergessen mädchen mitzunehmen
ich halte auch immer mal so ein bisschen
nach existenzen ausschau die hier
übrigens der zweite tote im stream das
war megageil java gegen die schlug gegen
gesprochen
auch man aber ich weiß auch gar nicht
mehr die koordinaten auch drauf bin
da hinten ist das haus
ich wette alle zuschauer sind schon
wieder am schreiben ich werde alle
schreiben schon wieder mit die
koordinaten rein bringt mir allerdings
aber nichts ich möchte jetzt auch nicht
in der aufnahme einfach nachschauen was
die koordinaten sind und ich werde das
jetzt mal ganz kurz
ich mag das eigentlich nicht wenn es
komplett hell ist ich werde jetzt
allerdings mal machen damit ich etwas
sehe ich das jetzt auch noch ganz viele
monster spawn und ich jetzt hier richtig
im eimer bin ich die arme fallen aber
das hab ich natürlich nicht drauf rein
der barbaren das kann ich das nicht eben
auf eine karte setzen auf meiner karte
sehen
schlechter hätte noch mehr dass noch
eine killer ein teil haben wir schon
wieder wm spieler vier hexen karl
essenzen sponti eigentlich irgendwie
auch mal neu oder oder wachsen die ja
einfach nur weiß nicht ich möchte jetzt
auch keine ganze folge damit verbringen
da irgendwie hin zu latschen a
daran kann ich mich aber erinnern an
diese stelle hier jedoch nicht einfach
scheiße doch nicht nur erschwert mit
schwert mit wusste es fehlt ebenfalls
ich bin ich aber auch hergelaufen
ich glaube ich bin dann hier drüber
gelaufen so ein bisschen nicht dass ich
jetzt irgendwie an der schlucht vorbei
gelaufen bin und dass sich die chance
zum laden gebracht habe das war
ärgerlich
aber das haus da kann ich mich auch noch
ändern ich bin nämlich doch nicht so
gelaufen sonst und gucke ich jetzt
gleich halt mal eben ganz kurz im stream
nach in dem video dann glaube ich mich
gleich mal ganz kurz
doch weil ich glaube ich bin da zu lange
gelaufen da müsste jetzt eigentlich im
kommen da auf der seite gehe dann will
ich jedoch falsch so läutet dann frage
ich mich mal ganz kurz hier in das
häuschen run bzw geh doch mal einfach
ein fackeln habe ich auch gar nicht mit
wieso dürfen ich gucke jetzt einmal ganz
kurz nach das sollte er sich allzu lange
dauern so ich habe immer mal das bild
ein bisschen hier im blick dass ich hier
auf jeden fall sehen kann ob ich nicht
auch noch irgendwie angegriffen werde
weil das wäre jetzt richtig doof
so machen dass man hier eben an das ist
doof dass ich jetzt damit meine zeit
hier mehr oder weniger mit verschwände
da da da da da da ist die stelle - 4000
scheiße - 4200 läuft auf jeden fall
schon mal richtig hin und 600 also nix
mit 804 ich muss noch viel weiter noch
da - 4200 600 - 4200 und 600 meiner
lieben damen und herren sind hier die
koordinaten wo ich verrückt bin
wir sind aber auch keine lizenzen mehr
münchner marcell als ein teil machen und
da oben darum ist alle die die greifen
bevor ich meine sachen wurde nicht dass
ich jetzt schon vorbei gelaufen bin und
ist jetzt geladen wird es war natürlich
nicht so toll spezialmittel oder schafft
das auch so
ich bin ja frei weniger amberg kletterer
bei der feier mehr
das cool kuratoren noch mehr hier
irgendwie und noch individuell und ich
uns ist ja auch nix mehr können einfach
runter jumpen unbedingten 4200
zu hier um dann ist ganz hin ist
mexikaner sense die hole ich mir gleich
und schaue jetzt erst mal ganz kurz hier
nach so waren das jetzt dahinter müsst
ihr dann eigentlich schon direkt die
schlucht liegen
ich bin viel zu weit auf dieser seite
finde ich in mir wünschen müsste die da
irgendwo sehen wenn jetzt wieder nach
oben da musst du design zu doof
koordinaten zu lesen
die 4200 sondern ich gucke immer nach
existenzen hüpfen
das ist doof dass ich jetzt fast eine
ganze folge mit seinem kack hier
verbringen musste ja da müsste dass er
dann irgendwo sein
ja da ist die schlucht de luca alle
meinten die sachen müssten noch da sein
weil die chance nicht geladen wurden sie
meinten zumindest alle ich schaue jetzt
noch das stimmt es ist mega drive das
sieht sogar noch meine erfahrung ist
mega drive dass ich halt gerade kein
ding mit habe kein schwert alter
wie geil es gibt einfach alles noch von
mir natürlich shop ich habe einfach
meine ganzen sachen wiedergefunden die
vita ich liebe dich fast nichts
mitgenommen oder nur das wichtigste welt
ich habe ja auch nichts gutes er danke
danke also wirklich jetzt mal ohne
hektik ausgegraben und jetzt nicht
gleich vier mal kam er von darunter und
ich habe mich dann erstmal dann dachte
ich so der macht spaß oder irgend sowas
hab ich mich hier hingestellt gewartet
bis er aufhört abgeschrieben cool so
habe ich geschrieben
cool so nach dem motto sommer langsam
auf sind nicht so toll dann auf ein
rettungsboot ich hatte noch halbe leben
an euch einfach dieser zeit geboxt und
auf einmal hatte der nur noch ein halbes
herz als ich hätte ihn locker gepanscht
im eins-gegen-eins mit meinen sachen die
ja nicht mal gut fahren aber ich glaub
drehbar ist megageil also ich denke ich
weiß nicht ich finde die meisten leute
haben halt hier so crazy daisy sachen
stuff machen so cobo farm und zu aber
ich habe mich jetzt wirklich anfangs nur
um die triebe als kann auch sei ich
gucke ja gar keinen anderen im hero weil
ich mich ja selbst immer so überraschen
lassen will so eigentlich mehr oder
weniger aber das ist auf jeden fall
hammergeil wo ich dachte schon ich
verletzt war und es ist auf jeden fall
mega geil dass meine ganzen sachen jetzt
noch sind in hellem jedoch da ach der
hat die trivial sache mitgenommen da
bleibt man ja ok hätte eigentlich alles
mitnehmen dürfen aber ich habe 15 15
ich habe 15 stück ich war nur noch diese
eine verfügt und dann mache ich mir
diese folge einfach nochmal die tour
über rüstung und als hätte ich den krieg
gegen debitor und gegen statt gelb uns
einfach auseinander da muss es noch mit
meiner stadt abklären uns was anderes
aber leute jetzt beginnt jetzt fängt
hier und spaß mal oder hinten ist die
existenz wir brauchen nicht einen
sondern von leben drin
dann ist auch noch nehmen jetzt einfach
mit ich könnte auch einfach ihr könnt
meine ex karlsruher machen zwei stunden
im livestream und sorry dass die
qualität so doof aber mein internet ist
einfach ist weil internet ist so gut wie
die unteren zehn prozent von deutschland
das war jetzt schon zum zehnten mal wenn
ich irgendwann dann umziehen und dann
studiere und dann
bis der bescheid dann wird alles besser
dafür leben wir dann besser ganze leben
übrigens mit ein paar leute unter diesem
video wo ich gesagt habe besoffen
minecraft ich war nicht besoffen also
ich war halt so noch angetrunken und
beim ausnüchtern und sohn voll viel
anders falsch aufgefasst und meint so
jahr
dieses video ist total scheiße naja also
ihr meinte zu mir mal wenn ich immer so
oft gepostet habe ja jungs bin laufe ich
kein video machen heute für euch sorry
auch jetzt habe ich ein schweinchen ach
komm bitte dich egal dass jungs das ist
nelly und das ist fatal
wer mit zwei schweinchen wir haben nelly
und ford nelly furtado wenn er die
verteilung nicht kennt das schloss
verpasste leben gegenseitig behindert
ihr müsst mit komm ich heiraten
egal ich meine schweine bande im kreis
los kommen alle mit wenn ihr nicht
mitkommt dann nicht und mann der lee
kommt mit dallas bester mann oder was
ich weiß es ist nicht nelly aber schnell
die nelly wir haben 19 existenzen jungs
die triebe rüstung kommt jetzt alle an
alle klugscheißer ich weiß die möhre
bleibt er liegen ich weiß er hat dann er
hat sie nicht gegessen aber egal und
foto wenn die irgendwie wieder verloren
gehen jetzt dann hole ich mir wieder
zwei neue bei diesem zu doof hier die
sinti machen rennen
die machen rechts kommt ja wer zuerst
oben ist bekommt eine möhre oder karotte
gott ist ja gar knapp und es ist total
total und ab können
da geht es gegönnt so nelly und
fotoportal und bisschen schneller liebe
überhaupt gerade richtig ich glaube
schon ich darf aber nicht gründen ich
bin auch voll und schaffen der cam
es tut mir auch ein bisschen leid so
wenig schlafe nicht so sitzen würde
aber nein das ist dieser blöde autofokus
fokussiert einfach blöd ich bin aber
froh dass wir die ganzen sachen wieder
haben dass vitor sich nicht alles wieder
mitgenommen hat das auch noch eine aber
ich glaube sogar devito hat sich meine
sachen mitgenommen was waren meine
sachen die ich mir dann aus meiner kiste
geholt aber dann bin ich ja wieder dahin
gelaufen
jetzt kommt ihm alle teuer ich weiß ja
gar nicht wenn eli und ist und wer
furtado ist und alles ist noch kanye und
west das ist wenn einer uhr meteorit der
jungs packt jetzt auf ein bisschen de
formentor hit abgestellt es kann weiter
fasst die meteoriten mit präparat aber
ich glaube manöver meine schweine sind
meine schweinchen sind so klug dass sie
endlich wissen dass man sich bei diesem
komischen teilnehmer nicht wahrnehmen
lernen ist auch scheißegal kommt es mit
wenn jetzt nicht mitkommen hallo jungs
ja nun kommt mit und due forni und
vorbei kommt zwei kommen alle so wir
sind aber wie er ja kaum noch ähnlich
läuft bei uns
wir sind aber glaube ich das schon
wieder zu hause nur die letzte
koordinator muss mit 1200 stehen ich
gucke mal oben auf die medienmacher ich
mach das jetzt einfach so dass da auch
zürich das super bild ich gucke dann
einfach immer rings und links und rechts
neben ist oder cool so einfach so nach
der karte laufen weil ich in der
schlosserei und bin tot
was wäre so witzig wenn sie mir dann
wieder komplett mit nein kommt du das
auch mitkommen
ok wenn du nicht willst komm halt nur
die und ford ado mit keep your head
die rezession macht nochmal ein sound
der entente in den tecdax kommen
familienvater war zu hause furtado
furtado und und eva kortmann
wir sind schon nach 18 minuten man das
toplos am anfang einer ganz kurzen menü
das heißt zwei minuten geht noch ich
weiß nicht ob es in der zeit schaffte zu
hause zu kommen musste die beiden
alleine lasse mir wenn ich zu hause
wenig bringen würde
ich will ja nicht sprinten das schaffen
aber nicht gläubig oder komme ich lasse
jetzt darf die hier nicht alleine lassen
jungs sind das sind furtado und nec ich
darf die eigentlich gar nicht einlassen
max mehr kommt jetzt mit krebs los nein
guck guck dir das nicht an
das ist böse das ist böse das sind
mammuts eisbären mammut eisbär mammut
qual überall stützen meteoriten hier ab
wie krass dachten meteorit eher selten
oder sowas den gefunden habe denkste
omerika des rennens aus wir sind aber
gleich wieder zu hause also leute links
also da oben
erich zeigt dahin egal was ihr jetzt
unten links seht da ist unsere stadt
glaube ich zeig dir meine komplette wenn
ihr irgendwie tipps habt schreibt mir
die in die kommentare aber wir schon
sagen das ist ein insider nennen die
nicht krank sondern wenn ihn korrekt so
richtiger cracker jack reacher häuser
1957 und auch ich sehe da hinten schon
die stadt ja die sache ist die ich muss
jetzt beenden die nächste folge werde
ich auch noch alleine machen wo ich
hoffe ihr fallt nicht daran weil da wo
ich euch bestimmt nicht raus
die nächstfolgende auch wieder alleine
machen ich hier schon mal vom server
herunter die nächste folglich auch
wieder alleine machen weil ich daran
trikots zu machen werdet ihr nicht
direkt im anschluss auf die werdet ihr
dann morgen sehen dann bin ich auch ein
bisschen schärfer wieder in der fei scam
ich bin da so schon scharf nein spaß und
dann sehen uns morgen wieder beziehen
was wir sehen uns wieder wenn ihr mich
wieder sehen wollt